bonsoir voici les titres de l'actualité
de ce mardi 13 juillet sixième jour
d'affrontements en iran entre étudiants
et forces de l'ordre les manifestants
refusent les appels au calme du pouvoir
et notamment du président khatami un
rapport parlementaire met en cause les
méthodes de gestion de la mutuelle
nationale étudiante la mnef mais les
critiques se limitent la nécessité de
réformer cette gestion les agriculteurs
appelé à suspendre l'épandage des boues
des stations d'épuration sur leurs
terres ces boues sera l'origine de
nombreuses pollutions 9e étape du tour
de france la victoire très nette de
l'américain lance armstrong provoque des
bouleversements au classement général
cela fait maintenant six jours que des
accrochages parfois très violents ont
lieu à téhéran mais aussi dans plusieurs
autres villes iraniennes entre des
étudiants des jeunes et les différentes
forces de police envoyée par le pouvoir
des mollahs un même pouvoir qui pourtant
multiplient les appels au calme mais ces
appels ne semble pas avoir de chance
d'être entendu tant les manifestants
n'ont plus peur de la répression du
régime religieux commentaires gérard
griesbeck
officiellement tout est en train de
rentrer dans l'ordre la police a pris
position autour de l'université
en réalité les affrontements n'ont pas
cessé depuis hier au soir
les arrestations non plus des centaines
de jeunes ont été appréhendés par la
police aidée par les milices islamistes
les appels au calme lancés par le
président khatami n'ont pas été entendus
ces jeunes qui soutiennent leur
président dans sa lutte pour la
modernisation du pays ont enclenché un
mouvement qui a maintenant sa propre
dynamique
le président rami veut réformer le pays
pas à pas et gagner les élections
législatives de février prochain mais
les étudiants ne veulent plus attendre
au risque de déborder les réformateurs
hélas
je tuerai je tuerai celui qui a tué mon
frère
mon des étudiants et très peu organisés
très peu structuré c'est un mouvement
qui est extrêmement spontané il n'y a
pas de porte parole il n'y a pas de
leader il n'y a pas de responsables
qu'ils expriment ouvertement au nom des
étudiants dit la situation est
extrêmement mobile elle peut évoluer
deux en heure
c'est là en fait neige ce matin un imam
proche du président khatami est venu
rencontrer les étudiants pour apaiser
leur colère
ce qu'a fait la police est impardonnable
c'est contraire à la loi du pays le
mouvement des étudiants est maintenant
soumis à la répression le président rami
vient de les lâcher s'exprime à l'heure
actuelle à la télévision sans doute pour
ne pas prendre le risque d'une
destitution par les conservateurs
gérard grisey viens de vous le dire le
président khatami président iranien
pourtant a priori favorable aux jeunes
et aux réformes s'exprime en ce moment
même à division iranienne où il a
vivement condamné les violentes
manifestations
les actes sont contraires aux intérêts
de notre nation de notre système et des
programmes du gouvernement ce qui
n'était au début qu'un mouvement
étudiant pacifique est il dit s'est
transformé en une menace violente pour
la sécurité de l'iran fin de citation
des propos de monsieur rate amis qui
viennent d'être diffusées par la
télévision iranienne à téhéran
la procureure du tribunal pénal
international pour l'ex yougoslavie
louise arbour est arrivé aujourd'hui au
kosovo il y a 6 mois elle avait été
refoulé à la frontière pour les
autorités yougoslave sur orb de ce que
vlad milosevic à la marc burg s'est
rendu au quartier général de la force
internationale de paix après stinat elle
avait auparavant indiqué que de
nombreuses inculpation était à prévoir
pour les atrocités commises au kosovo et
selon madame à rebours le processus vers
le jugement de milosevic est
irréversible ce sera l'un des dossiers
de préoccupation du nouveau représentant
spécial des nations unies bernard
kouchner
celui ci arrivera jeudi au kosovo et
avec lui pour la première fois l'onu
devra gérer entièrement un territoire
tout est à faire ou à refaire tout est à
reconstruire mais il faut aller vite
estime bernard kouchner dans le domaine
judiciaire ou le système était aux mains
exclusives dessert depuis dix ans les
débuts d'une administration de la
justice paritaire sont hésitants voire
difficile
comment rendre la justice avec équité
voici avec le reportage d'agnès
vahramian et nathalie gallet les
tentatives de réponse au jour le jour
l'unique je fis albanais d'une fonction
les bureaux des juges serbes
ils ont fui des tirs à l'arrivée des
troupes de l'otan
le système judiciaire c'est par était
aussi le 26 mai dernier
depuis dix ans les serbes avaient
confisqué la justice au kosovo
sur 750 magistrats dans la province 30
seulement et paypal vallée en quinze
jours venus a mis sur pied un groupe de
neuf juges et procureurs désigné
provisoirement province on les harcèle 5
albanais trois serbes
un turc itinérant transporter et
protéger par la kfor prison de prizren
dans le sud
les détenus de la police militaire
allemande ont remplacé ceux des serbes
emmenés en serbie par la troupe
yougoslave et dont on est sans nouvelles
ceux-ci des albanais sont présumés
voleurs au pyromane l'unique serbe
interpellé par les allemands est
soupçonné d'avoir tué deux albanais dans
une bagarre
le juge lui précise que lui et albanais
mais qu'il l'encouragea s'exprimait en
serbe langue qu'il comprend l'onu qui
considère que le kosovo fait encore
partie de la fédération yougoslave a
souhaité que le code pénal de serre dues
continue de s'appliquer
les magistrats albanais choisi par l'onu
sont gênés sur ce sujet ils ont continué
à travailler avec les serbes ces
dernières années et craignent les
soldats de lourches et qu'à présent dans
le couloir de la prison
le tchèque a tant ici de sortir un de
ces hommes détenus les soldats allemands
disent ne pas céder à ces pressions mais
les séparatistes supporte mal que le
code pénal serbe symbole de l'oppression
soit encore appliqué surtout il traque
de collaborateurs tous ces juges même
les albanais
à l'écart le procureur serbe explique
qu'il n'a pas peur en tant que magistrat
mais quand on conserve sa maison a été
dévastée et qu'il craint d'autres en
représailles ses juges un jour pourrait
bien d'instruire des affaires de crimes
de guerre quel sera alors leur sérénité
l'onu tente de faire de la justice au
kosovo un exemple de démocratie de multi
ethnisme mais ce n'est pour l'instant
qu'un laboratoire aux juristes
internationaux
pendant ce temps en serbie la
contestation s'amplifie contre le régime
de slobodan milosevic et les
manifestations ont gagné la voïvodine au
nord de la serbie
l'opposition continue à demander la
démission d'hugues lodevic la mairie de
la ville de vannes gévaudan l'oiseau la
serbie a été attaqué et des pétitions
circulent y compris comme ici dans le
centre-ville de belgrade toujours pour
obtenir le départ de slobodan milosevic
en colombie des combats très violents
ont eu lieu ces derniers jours entre les
forces gouvernementales et la guérilla
communiste celle ci regroupés dans les
forces armées révolutionnaires de
colombie les farc
forte de douze mille hommes menaient une
vaste offensive france yves
officiellement stoppées selon l'armée
colombienne
mais au prix de très nombreux morts dont
des dizaines d'enfants commentaires
maryse burgot c'est une présentation à
la presse
le gouvernement colombien entend montrer
que la récente offensive de la guérilla
communiste est brisée 40 cadavres des
hommes mais aussi beaucoup d'enfants
tous engagés dans l'un des plus anciens
et plus meurtrier mouvements de combat
d'amérique latine
les farc ces images illustrent le
véritable communiqué de victoire diffusé
aujourd'hui par les forces armées
régulières colombienne fidèles à
l'actuel président andrés pastrana les
militaires exhibe aussi les armes
qu'elles ont confisqué à la guérilla on
réalise alors à quel point les
combattants des farc sont bien équipés à
quel point les négociations de paix qui
devait redémarrer dans une dizaine de
jours seront difficiles 40 ans cela fait
40 ans que les quinze mille combattants
des farc défient les autorités
colombiennes au nom de la révolution
marxiste leur trésor de guerre est
alimenté par les rançons après
enlèvement de 6
ils ont par le prélèvement d'impôt sur
la culture de la coca depuis 48
les combats entre ses hommes et l'armée
régulière ont fait plus de 120 mille
morts pour tenter d'amener la guérilla
vers la table des négociations
le gouvernement lui a attribué une zone
démilitarisée grande comme la syphilis
en échange de ses pairs les farc devait
accepter le principe d'un cessez le feu
c'était il y a huit mois depuis les
combats n'ont jamais cessé
suite du bras de fer entre le kazakhstan
et la russie à propos de la base de
lancement de fusées de baïkonour
théoriquement demain à partir de demain
un vaisseau de ravitaillement doit
partir rejoindre la station mir où se
trouvent notamment jean pierre haigneré
cette opération présentée par les russes
comme la dernière chance pour prolonger
la mission actuelle de mire mais il faut
pour cela
résoudre le contentieux avec le
kazakhstan reportage de notre
correspondant à moscou gilles rabin avec
franck brisset la station mir et est
déjà victime de son âge de la crise
économique et de l'histoire
la voilà maintenant otage d'une crise
diplomatique il faut dire qu'on a eu
très peur la semaine dernière dans les
steppes du kazakhstan après l'explosion
d'une fusée
peu après le décollage et qu'on n'est
pas passé loin d'une catastrophe
je regarde à en l'air je veux suis truc
tombé dans ma cour dans un nuage de
poussière du fumet j'ai eu si peur
j'en ai fait une crise démarche la
république du kazakhstan elle aussi en a
fait une crise de nerfs
interdiction de tout décollage de
baïkonour y compris pour progress le
cargo spatial ravitailleur de mire qui
devait décoller demain
affolement côté russe sans
ravitaillement distille il faudra
abréger la mission dirigée par le
français jean pierre haigneré me
risquent ensuite de perdre son orbite et
de retomber sur terre en mars ou en
avril prochain
imaginez les masses folle de 140 tonnes
il semble bien que les russes et noirci
le tableau
peut-être parce qu'ils ont oublié de
payer au kazakhstan le loyer de la base
de baïkonour
et pas seulement cette année je suis
fort mais il n'y a pas d'urgence il ya
aucun problème critique
actuellement c'est à dire que s'il n'y a
pas de cargo serait peut-être amené
je suis pas sûr à raccourcir la mission
s'est même passion aujourd'hui mais en
tout cas rien ne serait fait dans
l'urgence on travaillera avec les russes
pour étudier la situation dans le détail
ici par gentillesse ont souri aux échos
de scénario catastrophe très fin de
millénaire qui inquiéterait les français
patriotes millénariste pour devenir le
nouveau siècle qui va commencer verra
peut-être invitation qui va arrêter son
travail le beau travail qu'elle a fait
depuis 13 ans mais de toute façon une
suite et tout ça avec une nouvelle
passion qui passe m au poids
allez on est en attente de ce rapport
une fois en france dans le département
du gers l' enquête sur le cadre ploemeur
de néerlandais commis fin mai à montfort
continuer la personne suspectée restent
détenus s'agit d'un homme de 35 ans
monsieur kamel ben salah
incarcéré depuis le 24 juin sa demande
de mise en liberté a été rejetée
aujourd'hui par la chambre d'accusation
de la cour d'appel d'agen
pourtant la compagne de monsieur ben
cela affirme qu'il est innocent
reportage christophe la rocca et david
bres le titre en couverture l'annoncent
ce n'est pas un rapport sur la mnef
cette mutuelle étudiante est proche du
ps
la justice enquête sur sa gestion et sur
des soupçons de financement politique
mais les députés de la commission
denquête en majorité des socialistes ont
préféré mener leurs investigations sur
l'ensemble des mutuelles étudiantes
officiellement la mnef c'est un cas
parmi d'autres la menotte l'a d'abord
servi aux étudiants
et elle a bien sûr lui les voiles alors
pardon pour cette inversion nous
évoquerons le dossier la nef et ce
rapport parlementaire qui a été publié
aujourd'hui mais auparavant nous allons
voir comme je vous le proposait il ya
quelques secondes
la situation de cette enquête policière
concernant le cadre que le mur de
néerlandais à montfort dans le gers et
le rejet de la demande de mise en
liberté du principal suspect
reportage de christophe la rocca et
david bres si nous pouvons le voir
maintenant tandis que les enquêteurs de
jandin continue de privilégier cela
arrive ce matin au palais de justice
d'agen sandrine sa compagne vissotto
elle espère encore qu'il sera libéré
mais après cinq heures de débats
le jeune homme est maintenu en détention
alors elle décide de s'adresser à la
presse j'ai des gens il faut pas être
humain moi je sais pas mais c'est pas ni
nu'man c'est pas vrai c'est tout le
contraire
au contraire il a un coeur gros comme si
kamel ben salah retourne en prison
c'est en large partie à cause de
l'utilisation des cartes bancaires des
victimes
dans les trois jours qui ont suivi le
drame des opérations très nombreuses
dans près de cette ville différente à
deux reprises à auchy roques sur garonne
les enquêteurs ont établi que kamel ben
salah se trouvait dans les environs
immédiats
c'est le cas dans cet hypermarché de la
région toulousaine le couple y effectue
pour plus de 5000 francs d'achats deux
jours après le quadruple meurtre un
retrait et même effectué dans ce guichet
le matin où kamel ben salah effectué un
achat dans cette bijouterie à quelques
dizaines de mètres
qu'ils soient au même endroit que ce
lieu où les endroits ont été retirés ça
prouve quoi ça font vos strictement rien
prouvé - ou qu'on me prouve au pardon
pas vous quand on me prouve que c'est
lui qui a affecté les retraites en est
dans ce dossier quand même les agences
bancaires pour celles qui sont équipées
de caméras de vidéosurveillance à marche
pas on peut pas les voir deux gouttes de
sang de kamel ben salah ont été
retrouvés dans la ferme des hollandais
ainsi que deux empreintes digitales
laissées sur le ruban adhésif servant à
lier les victimes
pour les avocats les traces normal
laissé par un homme qui bricolait au
noir pour les néerlandais il préfère
mettre en avant la première piste celle
du tueur en série allemand je sais qu'on
trouve une voiture allemande qui a été
volée en allemand et je sais que ce type
on me dit
il aurait peut-être ou qu'il serait
l'auteur présumé du meurtre commis en
allemagne par égorgement
après que les victimes ont été ligotées
et avec des coups de couteau portés au
coeur une voiture allemande a
effectivement été abandonnés ici à 25 km
de montfort deux heures avant le drame
une énigme non résolues comme reste
ouverte la question d'éventuelles
complicités pour ce quadruple meurtre
voilà pour cette enquête dans le gers
enfin sachez que ce dans la sphère de l'
incendie de la paillote chez francis en
corse les cinq gendarmes mis en examen y
compris le colonel henry mazères
viennent de retrouver une nouvelle
affectation dans différents états majors
au sein de la gendarmerie sur le
continent ils avaient été suspendus de
leurs fonctions la fin du mois d'avril
au moment donc de leur mise en examen
enfin dans le gard le petit garçon
austin âgé de neuf ans et demi disparue
depuis samedi après-midi d'une scie
familiale à alès a toujours pas été
retrouvé de nombreux policiers
poursuivent actuellement les recherches
pour retrouver le petit hocine
publication aujourd'hui du rapport de l'
enquête parlementaire sur la mutuelle
nationale des étudiants de france selon
les députés la mnef n'a pas respecté les
obligations fixées par le code de la
mutualité où des sociétés
dans le rapport on évoque une véritable
nébuleuse autour de la gestion la nef
mais si la commission denquête affirme
la nécessité d'une réforme des pratiques
de gestion
elle évite de mettre en cause
directement certains de ses anciens
dirigeants politiques de gauche
enquête olivier carol
le titre en couverture l'annoncent ce
n'est pas un rapport sur la menace cette
mutuelle étudiante est proche du ps
la justice enquête sur sa gestion et sur
des soupçons de financement politique
mais les députés de la commission
denquête en majorité des socialistes ont
préféré mener leurs investigations sur
l'ensemble des mutuelles étudiantes
officiellement la mnef c'est un cas
parmi d'autres l'avenant elle a d'abord
servi aux étudiants et elle a bien servi
les étudiants bon certes y'a eu de
débordements il y eu des
dysfonctionnements vous savez celle
écume des jours ça pour la commission
denquête voici le principal responsable
du scandale de la mnef
olivier spithakis il était le directeur
général de la mutuelle jusqu'à l'automne
dernier
sous son règne les filiales plus ou
moins opaques se sont multipliées selon
le rapport parlementaire
un système s'est progressivement mis en
place de plus en plus tentaculaire
le système s'est développé en dehors de
toute considération des intérêts des
étudiants
la commission est également sévère pour
l'ancienne présidente du conseil
d'administration
une étudiante du sud de la france qui ne
pouvait pas se rendre à paris lors des
réunions de direction
conclusion des députés le conseil
d'administration de la mnef a fonctionné
comme une chambre d'enregistrement
un organisme était pourtant censée
contrôler la mnef l'inspection générale
des affaires sociales mais l'igas a mis
très longtemps à dénoncer les dérives de
la mnef je ne comprends lequel igas a
toujours fait ce qu'on lui demandait de
faire c'est à dire que quand la
commission de contrôle des mutuelles lui
a demandé d'aller s'intéresser de très
près aux filiales de la mer en
particulier
d'autres d'autres mutuelles régionales
et bien lâcher tant qu'on lui avait pas
demandé de le faire ne l'a pas fait
cette réponse semble un peu courte à ce
député communiste
il a fait partie de la commission
denquête il affirme que le ps a cherché
à noyer le poisson
manifestement il n'y avait pas une
grande volonté de créer cette commission
denquête on a dit on peut on peut tout
voir
sauf ceux qui relèvent maintenant
puisqu'il y avait mise en examen il ya
des ja des mises en examen la justice
est saisie sur un certain nombre de
questions tout ça on n'a pas le droit de
le voir un rapport sans révélation donc
les députés ont décrit le système nef
mais on ignore encore à quoi il servait
condamnation d'alain carignon pour sa
gestion de la société d'économie mixte
j'ai idée monsieur k réunion a été
condamné à 18 mois de prison avec sursis
pour abus de biens sociaux dans le nord
du finistère sur la commune de tréflez
2000 personnes gens du voyage se sont
installés avec leurs centaines de
caravanes sur les dunes de keremma ce
rassemblement doit célébrer par des
baptêmes l'anniversaire d'une mission
évangélique rattachée à la fédération
protestante mais les dunes de calama
sont un site naturel et sur la commune
de tréflez on ne voit pas d'un bon oeil
d'une telle réunion
reportage olivier sio initial hiver ils
se sont installés ici sur ces dunes de
keremma tout près de la plage ou
dimanche
ils doivent procéder à des baptêmes
rituel dans la mer deux militants venus
de tout l'ouest de la france célébrer le
cinquantième anniversaire de leur
communauté protestante
le problème c'est que ces dunes sont un
site naturel protégé
même si les gens du voyage ne voit pas
très bien quel intérêt écologique peut
avoir cette lande apparemment désolé
nous avons cherché partout mais il n'y a
pas de terreau est adéquat bresse et un
grand sens n'a pas de terrain pour nous
est le seul endroit où on pouvait
s'installe avec tout le talent sans
gêner personne parce que nous sommes
dans un endroit désertique sur des dieux
nous avec du sable et des mouettes
donc on gêne personne et sylvia propice
pour la prière parce que c'est calme et
pourtant site classé les dunes de
keremma sont réputés pour leurs
orchidées et leur faune du coup le
conservatoire du littoral propriétaire
des lieux a porté plainte pour
occupation illégale et détériorations en
en faisant une affaire de principe
que ce soit des gens du voyage une rave
party ou un autre type de groupe social
une concentration de caravanes sur un
site inscrit protégée au titre de la loi
électorale par le conservatoire on ne
pouvait pas tolérer plus longtemps la
présence d'un grand groupe de caravanes
qui a complètement détruit certaines
parties du site
en attendant une hypothétique décision
de justice les communes riveraines elles
ont choisi les grands moyens
les accès aux autres du nom était bouché
dans la crainte de nouvelles arrivées
leurs élus mettent en cause la
responsabilité des villes plus
importantes la loi contre l'exclusion
prévoit que les communes de plus de 5000
habitants à des terrains à la
disposition des gens du voyage
malheureusement ces communes qui peuvent
en avoir non pas de terrasse est
important pour recevoir une telle
population
cette obligation de la loi la plupart
des communes l'acceptent de toute façon
difficilement les gens du voyage
s'étonne qu'au moment où la bretagne
accueille des centaines de milliers de
campeurs venus de toute l'europe
quelques dizaines de caravanes
supplémentaires provoque un si grand
tapage la fédération nationale des
syndicats d'exploitants agricoles fnsea
appelle tous les agriculteurs de france
à suspendre l'épandage des boues sur
leurs terres
cette pratique des stations d'épuration
implique des pollutions intoxications et
nuisances diverses les agriculteurs de
l'iphone et sera sans doute sensible à
l'air du temps et au souci de protection
de l'environnement exprimées par les
consommateurs pourraient ainsi bloqué
toutes les stations d'épuration exemple
près de niort dans les milliers de
tonnes de boues se trouvaient notamment
des éléments de métaux lourds enquête
françois privat et alain darrigrand
cette année jean marc renaud dorfhus
l'épandage des boues de station
d'épuration sur ses terres après les
moissons cellou fournis gratuitement par
la ville de niort sont étalées sur
plusieurs dizaines d'hectares de champs
pour les fertiliser en attendant elles
sont stockées en pleine nature
ce qui peut être un peu choquant c'est
là dans la conception de la fosse
effectivement c'est l'axé qui est assez
facile par le grillage donc un accès
pour les hommes ou pour les animaux qui
est assez facile et puis elles sont
creusées à même le sol donc il ya les
problèmes d'infiltration de métaux
lourds et de tout produit qui peut
s'infiltrer dans le sol des métaux
lourds comme le plomb le nickel ou
encore le mercure peuvent être présents
dans ces boues considéré par ailleurs
comme un bon engrais riche en azote et
phosphates la ville de niort en
rejettent 5000 tonnes chaque année son
service eau et assainissement effectué
tous les contrôles imposés par la loi et
une grève de l'épandage risque de poser
de gros problèmes
l'épandage et vous c'est la solution la
plus intelligente pour tout le monde au
niveau recyclage
or si on ne peut pas les épandre dans
l'état actuel département il n'ya pas
l'incinération
ça y est on est obligé d envoyer une
décharge à la mi juin luc guyau le
président de la fnsea a donc appelé tous
les agriculteurs de france à suspendre
l'épandage ici dans les deux sèvres où
de nombreux éleveurs de poulets viennent
de subir les conséquences de la sphère
de la dioxine
la mobilisation semble importante en cas
de pépin il est absolument anormal que
ce soit les agriculteurs qui paie les
dégâts alors que ça doit être les
producteurs debout tout simplement toute
activité humaine génère de la pollution
donc les agriculteurs et bien je pense
qu'ils essayent aujourd'hui
de ne pas vouloir payer cette taxe sur
les activités polluantes considérant que
eh bien ils sont au-dessus probablement
des lois
cette grève de l'épandage prend des
allures de pression sur les pouvoirs
publics qui prévoit dès l'année
prochaine de taxer les agriculteurs sur
l'utilisation des pesticides
la députée parlementaire européenne de
l'udf
madame nicole fontaine sera la candidate
du groupe majoritaire au sein du
parlement européen le ppe parti
populaire européen pour être la future
présidente de cette assemblée de
strasbourg demain à l'issue du défilé du
14 juillet sur les champs elysées à
partir de 13 heures sur france 2 le
président de la république s'exprimera
comme traditionnellement tous les jours
de fête nationale
et c'est peu dire que la classe
politique guettera les questions que
nous lui poserons demain sur les
conséquences de l'échec de la droite aux
dernières élections européennes
l'opposition s'interrogent sur la
cohabitation et la durée du mandat
présidentiel entre autres reportages
alban nicosie et ilana moryoussef
encouragements et bain de foule
le tout récent déplacement de jacques
chirac dans le bordelais avait déjà
comme un petit bout de campagne
électorale
sous-entendu le président est serein pas
du tout affaibli par les échecs
successifs de l'opposition ni d'ailleurs
car ses divisions
bon d'accord et maintenant semblent
répondre dirigeants et élus de droite
qui attendent finalement beaucoup de
l'intervention du 14 juillet il doit
marquer son identité sa différence et
les solutions que lui-même préconise et
les principes qui le soutient sont
évidemment à l'opposé de ceux de la
gauche jacques chirac tout à la fois
président de la république et chef de
l'opposition
la posture est délicate mais beaucoup à
droite jugent que la cohabitation est
trop consensuelle est trop favorable à
lionel jospin
la cohabitation les français se rendent
bien compte qu'elle tourne à pleaux
concubinage
valéry giscard d'estaing va même plus
loin dans une interview au monde entre
deux critiques
il indiqua jacques chirac qu'il existe
une solution c'est le quinquennat une
idée aujourd'hui reprise par certains à
l'udf comme andré santini qui propose
même un scénario au président de la
république
le président dispose du moment du choix
c'est lui qui pourra éventuellement par
un référendum par une démission pour
s'appliquer le quinquennat décider du
moment il n'est pas souhaitable que
cette cohabitation aille à son terme
pas sûr que jacques chirac ne reprenne
cette idée mais le voilà attendu dans
son intervention il devrait fixer une
sorte de rendez vous au gouvernement le
31 décembre par exemple une date
symbolique pour dresser un bilan et
prendre alors éventuellement des
initiales de première ronde main et
demain sur les champs elysées à partir
de 10 heures en direct sur france 2 et
première troupe a défilé seront les
hommes de la garde royale marocaine le
roi hassan ii sera aux côtés du
président chirac aujourd'hui il a eu un
entretien en tête à tête avec le premier
ministre monsieur lionel jospin à
l'issue de cet entretien le roi du maroc
a également rencontré des chefs
d'entreprise français
ces cérémonies du 14 juillet feront
l'objet d'une matinée complète de
reportages et de direct sur france 2
j'ai un peu les énumérer à partir de 7
heures dans télématin et du reportage de
laurence piquet christophe tortora et
valérie fournis ou sur la garde royale
marocaine sur le rôle de l'armée
française au kosovo et puis il y aura
donc des filets commenté par patrick
locaux qu'à partir de 9h55
quant aux derniers préparatifs pour le
feu d'artifice ils ont eu lieu
aujourd'hui
les pétards devrait évoquer les comédies
musicales du 20e siècle
reportage géraldine d'alban morena c'est
dominique bonnet pour réussir un feu
d'artifice mémorable on a besoin d'une
eau et de bombes de fusées de chandelle
mais surtout de professionnels depuis
vendredi une trentaine d'artifice et
s'active sur l'esplanade du trocadéro
oncle où on branche on manie 10 tonnes
de poudre presque sans la moindre
appréhension avoir du métier
quand on a vu le métier soit pas dans
notre cas pour parfumer à côté faut être
attentif donc on est tous à temps qu'il
faut les vins les uns aux autres on
regarde tous et on n'hésite pas à dire
des fausses fièvre dengue solide hier il
faut aussi un thème le spectacle de
demain sera consacrée aux plus célèbres
comédies musicales du xxème siècle de
singin in the rain à notre dame de paris
un show tout en musique en lumière et
bien sûr en feu d'artifice plus de 3
millions de projectiles illumineront le
ciel de paris
tous commandé par un seul ordinateur
contrôler toute l'esplanade du trocadéro
au niveau feux d'artifice une
technologie de pointe au service damas
c'est très difficile à expliquer c'est
une passion c'est c'est le beau c'est
pour nous c'est la fête c'est bon c'est
de satisfaire au maximum le public et
c'est de la création si au niveau
artistique on va recréer des figures on
va on redessine apple si elle en train
il faut un public l'an dernier plus de
400 mille personnes s'étaient déplacées
pour assister au spectacle
sport cyclisme tour de france une
neuvième étape avec une formidable
victoire pour l'américain lance
armstrong à sestrières après plus de 213
km non ça me semble conforte largement
son maillot jaune en démontrant une
supériorité incontestable dès la
première étape de montagne
reportage florent gautreau et philippe
deslandes armstrong leur a fait très mal
le suisse alex du le deuxième de l'étape
à 38 secondes ne parvient pas à
récupérer de sa vaine poursuite derrière
l'amérique
et quand il arrive à parler ces mots
traduits son impuissance j'ai encore
essayé à la fin de rattraper amstrong
mais c'était trop dur il était plus fort
aujourd'hui amstrong était plus fort
trop fort incroyablement fort comment ce
coureur qui n'a jamais été considéré
comme un pur grimpeur at il pu infliger
une telle leçon aux spécialistes de la
montagne lui seul à la réponse depuis le
galibier il était déjà dans le groupe
des neuf coureurs échappés et il
contrôle et sans problème du faux
virenque et gotti ses principaux rivaux
dans gotti et s karting prennent le
large au pied de l'ultime montée c'est
encore amstrong qui vient les chercher
son démarrage est impressionnant
virenque dufau et les autres ne peuvent
pas suivre mieux l'américain impose son
train à ses deux compagnons dans la
montée vers sestrières et 1,6 km 500 de
l'arrivée il place une accélération
progressive et décisive après le
prologue et le contre la montre de metz
lance amstrong s'aduge une troisième
étape et conforte son maillot jaune
olano deuxième du général est déjà à six
minutes et 3 secondes
je peux très bien avoir un jour sans
mais alors tout serait fini je dois
rester concentré mon équipe aussi
c'est le seul moyen de gagner cette
course l'autre homme heureux c'est
richard virenque il passe de la trente
septième à la neuvième place au
classement et surtout il récupère son
maillot fétiche de meilleur grimpeur
une tunique que je connais bien et moi
je suis content je suis confiant pour la
première étape de montagne
jetez là et demain ça ira sûrement mieux
s'améliore le varois s'est rappelé au
bon souvenir des organisateurs avec le
secret espoir de remporter une étape de
montagne comme il l'avait fait il ya
deux ans comme au bon vieux temps
alors malgré le mauvais temps malgré les
difficultés de circulation clé peut-être
vu cet après midi sur france 2 il y
avait beaucoup de monde de part et
d'autre de la route empruntée par les
174 coureurs encore en lice nous
voulions vous raconter cette ambiance
évoqué les attitudes des supporters
notamment à l'égard de richard virenque
et puis le hasard a fait que nathanaël
de rincquesen et alain poirier nous
envoyés spéciaux ont découvert parmi le
public
vili joutes l'ancien soigneur belge du
groupe festina celui là même qui par ses
aveux a fait découvrir l'ampleur du
dopage dans le cyclisme
cet après midi sur la route du tour les
véhicules festina de la caravane
publicitaire sont passés devant willy
voet l'ancien soigneur de richard
virenque
l'homme par qui tout est arrivé habite à
quelques kilomètres de là avec sa femme
pour faire plaisir à son fils votre
vient voir passer le tour en spectateurs
pour la première fois de sa vie où les
voûtes attend les coureurs non sans une
certaine anxiété 30 ans dans le cyclisme
20 tours de france ça laisse des traces
et des amis celui ci est ravi de
retrouver willy mais il ne veut pas être
filmés en sa compagnie les coureurs
arrivent les anciens collègues de willy
voet aussi dans le peloton
personne ne l'a oublié les voitures se
succèdent ainsi que les témoignages de
sympathie
arrive le moment tant redouté par willy
voet la tête de course
le groupe de richard virenque
visiblement ému l'ancien soigneur
festina va s'isoler quelques minutes
mais le reste du peloton arrive il ne
veut pas rater ça
alors franchement je suis content
ces [ __ ] de vélo 1
c'est dur
aujourd'hui où les voûtes a retrouvé le
tour il a aussi retrouvé le sourire
grâce à ce geste
willy voet doit partir en vacances dès
demain avec sa famille
la fin du tour il la suivra à la télé
peut-être si tout le temps automobile le
pilote allemand de formule 1 michael
schumacher blessé dimanche au grand prix
de grande bretagne est arrivé
aujourd'hui à genève il doit maintenant
se reposer après son opération de la
jambe droite
il lui faudra sans doute 12 semaines
douzaine de semaines pour se remettre de
la double fracture d'une petite a été
victime son remplaçant sera été choisi
par ferrari ce sera le finlandais mika
salo
l'été sera chaud mais d'été sera latino
en tout cas ce sont les spécialistes ès
musique branchée qui le disent en
prenant pour exemple la réussite de
sergent garcia un groupe français aux
influences cubaines et reggae dont
l'album est déjà vendue à plus de cent
mille exemplaires
sergent garcia ça rappelle 0 alors on
appelle au rom les ambitions acoustique
constaté par pierre emmanuel luneau et
d'intel et galets dans une petite rue de
l'est parisien sont plus subtiles que
les grognements du sergent de l'armée
mexique
on est quand même à vous fait pas de la
salsa plus anciens une fusion et se
retrouve dans la musique aussi bien les
tambours africains
les mélodies latines que des traces de
hip hop ou jazz une chose comme ça
sergent garcia c'est ça une espèce de
grand sandwich musical le bain il serait
français et la garniture fait de reggae
de musique cubaine et coupe la tête
d'habitude autour de bruno garcia le
chanteur au cigare ils sont une
quinzaine ni même en petit comité
le groupe n'est pas du genre à refuser
de pousser la chansonnette
bonjour je suis le sergent garcia et
voilà le contre ils jouent et se
mélangent ici en version allégée
sergio garcia le peaufine depuis bientôt
deux ans sur scène
et c'est là qu'il est en train de se
bâtir une solide réputation
et
gillet
m
au moins autant que les concerts sergent
garcia a une autre passion
cuba n'est qu' un son qui se produit
quelque part tout le monde sort et puis
ça va et tout qu'est ce qui se passe on
va danser on va te fasses aussi cela
easy cd qui a un son qu'on appelle la
police
mais hier les quelque chose d'important
si tu parles la communication ça pour
faire revenir la communication mais si
c'est tout fini tout ça
il est aussi le métissage de la
population là bas qui est vachement
important
il s'agit black espagnol
tous les caraïbes enfin tu vois on était
un peu de casse est ici de toutes ces
tribus là qui sont cloisonnés celui qui
écoute du rock du rap le reggae tout ça
c'est vraiment dans des boîtes comme les
diables sortant de la sienne sergio
garcia est en train d'imposer sa recette
musicale qui signent danger qui veut
dire garcia voilà nous arrivons à la fin
de ce journal je vous rappelle deux
informations que nous avons développées
tout d'abord le sixième jour de
contestation en iran et dans plusieurs
villes iraniennes
les affrontements entre étudiants et
forces de l'ordre sont de plus en plus
violent pour aider les terrans malgré
les appels au calme répétés notamment
ceux du président khatami qui condamne
ces violences
et marque donc sa différence avec ses
étudiants et ses jeunes qui s'affrontent
aux forces de l'ordre
et puis la très nette victoire de
l'américain lance armstrong à l'issue de
la 9e étape du tour de france a mis son
maillot jaune devant le deuxième olano
et olano et à plus de six minutes
maintenant de lancer dans quelques
secondes la météo avec nathalie rihouet
suivi du temps d'une chanson et frédéric
mitterrand à 1h15 laurence ostolaza ou
présentera ce dernier journal de la
rédaction
et puis donc dès 7 heures du matin une
émission spéciale consacrée au 14
juillet à 13h l'entretien avec le
président de la république en direct des
jardins de l'elysée suivi du journal
avec rachid arhab et carole gaessler et
puis je vous retrouve ensuite à 20h
bonsoir merci
l'image du